hi everyone this is edan and today i
will introduce our work on sublinear
time computation in the presence of
online erasers this is joint work with
social assad nicola at boston university
and nitin verma chennai mathematical
institute
initiate the study of sublinear time
algorithms that compute in the presence
of an online adversary
a sublinear time algorithm is a
randomized algorithm that has query
access to some very large dataset via an
oracle here is a depiction of a data set
and an analyst that has oracle access to
this data set
we represent the data set via function f
that takes examples to their label
the analyst runs an algorithm which
makes queries to the function f and
outputs some approximate answer about
this function the number of queries made
by the algorithm should be sublinear in
the size of the input function
the online adversary you consider is the
following after answering each query to
the data set the oracle or the adversary
can hide a small number of entries from
the analyst
in the next few slides i will formally
define both the adversarial model we
consider as well as the tasks we
consider within this model
let's start by defining the adversarial
model which we call the online erasers
model it is parameterized by a natural
number t
after answering each query of the
algorithm the adversarial oracle can
erase up to t entries from the input
function
i'll demonstrate the model for the case
when t equals to 1. before the algorithm
makes any queries all entries of the
function are non-erased suppose the
algorithms first query is entry to
then the oracle first has to answer this
query by returning f 2.
after answering the query of the
algorithm the oracle can now erase one
entry of the function suppose it chooses
to erase entry 3 then the value f of 3
will be hidden from the algorithm for
the remainder of its running time
if at some point the algorithm queries
entry 3 then it will receive a special
symbol perp
the process just described is then
repeated for all queries of the
algorithm
in this model we also assume that the
oracle knows the description of the
algorithm but it does not have access to
the random coins of the algorithm
we consider the following motivating
scenarios for studying this adversarial
model
the first scenario considers the case
when individuals requested their data be
removed for a data set as enabled for
example by eu general data protection
regulation
in particular such requests can be
adaptive to the algorithm's queries as
individuals can be prompted to restrict
access to their data after noticing an
inquiry into their or others data
another scenario is that of a criminal
investigation or fraud detection setting
a criminal could react by raising their
data after some of their records are
pulled by the authorities
finally in a legal setting when an
organization is served a subpoena it is
legally bound to answer the query
however afterwards they can destroy
related evidence that was not involved
in the subpoena
notice that in all of these scenarios
the erasures happen after the algorithm
receives an answer to its query which is
compatible with our modeling choice
in this work we consider property
testing tasks which are a special case
of sub-linear time algorithms
property testing was first introduced by
ruby fell sudan and called dragon
baceron
in this
model the algorithm is given a par
parameter epsilon between zero and one
and its goal is to determine whether f
has a specified property or if it is
epsilon fire from the property
by epsilon 5 we mean that f must be
modified in at least epsilon fraction of
its domain to have the property
then the tester is supposed to accept if
f has the specified property and reject
with high probability if f is epsilon
far from such property
since we are in sublinear regime we want
a tester that makes a sublinear number
of queries in the size of the input
notice that in this model we assume
perfect access to f which means that for
every query x the algorithm will receive
the true value f of x
other property testing models have been
studying where this assumption does not
hold
partners ron and rubyfelds initiated the
study of tolerant property testing where
a fraction of the values of f could be
corrupted and dictator as
honeycombattacorta and varma studied
eurasia resilient property testing
in this model a fraction of the values
of f have been erased however the
erasures happen before the algorithm
makes any of its queries for this reason
we will refer to the model of diction as
ad as the model of offline erasures
we study property testing when erasures
to the function f happen online as the
algorithm is making its queries the goal
of an epsilon online erasure resilient
tester is the same as that of a standard
tester it's supposed to accept if the
function has the specified property and
reject with high probability if it is
epsilon fire from the property the only
difference being that the access to the
function is via the online adversarial
oracle these are our results at a high
level we show that some properties can
be tested with the same query complexity
in the online erasers model as in the
standard model namely linearity and
quadraticity and here we're comparing
query complexity for a constant erasure
budget t
then for linearity we show matching
upper and lower bounds in terms of the
erasure budget t
on the other hand we show that some
properties are impossible to test in our
model even when t is equal to one namely
sortedness of arrays
as we will see the structure of the
violation to the property plays an
important role in determining
testability the plan for the rest of
this talk is to first introduce our
linearity tester with a sketch of the
analysis and then introduce the main
idea for our lower bound on linearity
testing
introduce just one idea from our
quadraticity tester in its analysis
and conclude with our result on the
possibility of testing sortedness let's
jump into linearity testing we consider
functions which are boolean valued and
whose domain are bit strings of length t
such a function is linear if f of x can
be written as the sum of the bits x i
for some subset s of the bits
equivalently a function is linear if f
of x plus f of y is equal to f of x plus
y for all x and y in the domain
linearity testing has been widely
studied due to its connections with
probabilistically checkable proofs and
hardness of approximation results
in the standard property testing model
linearity testing can be done with one
of our epsilon queries the tester was
first introduced by bloom lubia
rubinfeld and its analysis was later
improved by bellar coppersmith hashtag
kiwi and sudan
in our model we show that linearity
testing can be done with log t over
absolute enquiries where t is the number
of eurasias per query that can be made
by the adversary
the tester of bloom lubia and rubenfeld
is very simple it repeats the following
procedure
it samples x and y from the domain then
it queries f of x f of y and f of x plus
y and it rejects if f of x plus f of y
does not equal f of x plus y since this
cannot happen for a linear function
in this case we say that the pair x y
violates linearity
the analysis of the tester relies on the
following crucial result if a function f
is epsilon far from linear then an
epsilon fraction of the pairs x y will
violate linearity
it is very easy to see that the blr
tester will break in the presence of
online erasures
the tester could query x and y and
receive their values however once the
oracle answers with f y it can erase x y
and thus the tester would never see a
violation to linearity
as a result we will introduce a new
linearity tester which works in the
presence of online erasures
its analysis will rely on the following
structural theorem
if a function is epsilon far from linear
then for all even k an epsilon fraction
of the k tuples x 1 x 2 through x k by
late linearity
by which we mean that f of x 1 plus f x
2 up to f of x k does not equal the
value of f on the sum x1 plus x2 up to
xk
notice that the theorem of del r and al
is a special case of our structural
theorem for when k is equal to 2.
the proof of our structural theorem
follows via fourier analysis and uses
similar ideas as the proof of the
theorem of bellarell
our online erasure resilient linearity
tester is as follows
at first the tester queries 2 log t over
epsilon points x i which are sampled
uniformly and independently at random
from the domain
and recall that t is the number of
erasures per query
the tester then repeats the following
one over epsilon times
it samples an unempty set i of q of even
size
then it queries f of the sum of the
points x i for indices in the set
capital i
and it rejects if the sum of the points
f of x i does not equal the value of f
on the sum of the x i's
and all relevant values in this
calculation are non-erased
if after one of our epsilon repetitions
of this procedure the tester doesn't
catch a violation it will then accept
let's demonstrate the tester for the
case when t equals to 2.
suppose the tester for score is a point
x1
then another point x2
now the oracle can erase x1 plus x2
which we represent by an edge between
the two points
next the oracle queries another point x3
sampled from the domain
and the oracle can erase x2 plus x3 and
x1 plus x3
then again the tester queries a point x4
and the oracle erases two
potential sums x3 plus x4 and x2 plus x4
now the
tester can query sums between the
reserve of points and it can query
either x1 plus x4 in which case it would
be
lucky to query a non-erase point or it
could also query the sum x1 plus x2 plus
x3 plus x4 which would also be
non-erased
following is a sketch of the analysis of
the tester
note that the tester always accepts if f
is linear so we'll suppose now that the
function f is epsilon far from linear
in this case the goal of the tester is
to obtain non-erased all values of some
k-tuple that violates linearity and the
sum of the points in this k-tuple
notice that the points in step one are
quarried uniformly and independently at
random so if the size of the main is
large enough then the points are
non-erased with high probability when
quarried so from now on we assume that
the points scored in step 1 are
non-erased
and we analyze the probability that the
tester rejects in step 2.
the number of even sized subsets with
entries in the set q are 2 to the q
minus 1 which after replacing for the
value of q equals t squared over 2
epsilon squared
now the tester cares about finding a
violating tuple and by the structural
theorem the expected number of violating
tuples of even size is an epsilon
fraction of the even sized tuples
so epsilon times 2 to the q minus 1
which equals t square over 2 epsilon by
our previous calculation
the number of piloting sums that can be
raised by the adversary is t
times the number of quarries made by the
algorithm
the algorithm makes q plus one over
epsilon queries so the number of
eurasias by the adversary is upper
bounded by t times
q plus one over epsilon
which after replacing form the value of
q and some calculations is upper bounded
by three t log t over epsilon now notice
that the number of sums that are erased
by the adversary is much smaller than
the expected number of violating
tuples so we can show that the expected
fraction of non-erased violating sums is
at least epsilon over two
and after one of our epsilon iterations
the tester will sample a numeries
violating sum and reject with high
probability
that concludes the analysis of our
linearity tester next we will talk about
our lower bound for linearity testing
we show that every online erasure
resilient linearity tester must make at
least log t queries
and this matches our upper bound for
linearity testing in terms of dependence
on t
the proof idea is as follows
suppose a tester has access to a
function f where access is via an online
adversarial oracle
the oracle uses the following strategy
after answering each query of the tester
it erases t sums of previous queries of
the tester
if the tester makes queries where q is
strictly less than log t
then with t erasures the oracle can
erase at least 2q to the cue points
which means that the oracle can erase
all sums of the points queried by the
tester
and the tester only sees linearly
independent vectors from 0 1 to the d
so the tester will be able to see the
value of f on points like x1 x2 x3 which
are linearly independent but it would
not be able to see the value of f
on a point like x1 plus x2 since that
will have been erased by the oracle
a partial function which is defined only
on linearly independent vectors can be
extended to be either linear or far from
linear so the tester cannot distinguish
between the two two cases if it makes
less than log t queries
this proof can be made formal via yao's
minimax principle which is adapted to
our setting
yale's minimax principle is a very
common technique for proving lower
bounds in property
testing and that concludes our
discussion on the linearity lower bound
next we discuss some ideas from our
quadratic city tester
consider again boolean valued functions
defined on the bit strings such a
function is quadratic if it can be
expressed as a polynomial of degree at
most two for example the function f of x
equals to x one times x two plus x three
is a quadratic function
quadraticity testing has also been
widely studied for the same reasons as
linearity testing
in the standard model along kaufman
crevalle which leads in and runs show
that quadraticity can be tested with one
of our absolute queries
in the online erasures model we show
that quadraticity can be tested with one
over epsilon queries when t is constant
the query complexity has doubly
exponential dependence in t for this
tester
the tester of alone all repeats the
following procedure it samples three
points x y z uniformly at random from
the domain
then it queries the value of f on their
pairwise sums and on the sum of the
three points x plus y plus z
you will then reject if the sum of the
values of f on the seven points is one
since this cannot happen for a quadratic
function
we can represent the queries of the
tester via a triangle pictorially the
points x y z are the vertices of the
triangles
the edges are their pairwise sums x plus
y x plus z and y plus z
and the sum of the three points x plus y
plus z is the inside of the triangle
in designing our online eraser resilient
mod tester we design a two player game
that captures the main challenge in
obtaining such a violating structure in
the presence of eurasia
we'll describe the game in the next
slide
the two-player game proceeds in rounds
in each round player 1 which we think of
as the tester can either draw or vertex
or draw an edge connecting two vertices
or color the inside of a triangle in
blue
layer two has t moves and we think of
player two as the adversary in each move
it draws an edge between existing
vertices or colors the inside of a
triangle in red once something has been
drawn or colored in red it cannot be
colored or drawn over in blue
our question is whether player 1 can
draw all parts of one triangle that is
its vertices edges and color the inside
in blue
we answer this question in positive by
designing a winning strategy for player
1 with t to the order of t moves the
strategy is then converted into our
online eraser resilient quadraticity
tester
we'll demonstrate one part of this
winning strategy for the case when t
equals equal to one
suppose that player one has managed to
draw the following two structures in
blue consisting of vertices and edges
notice that some of the vertices are
labeled with x and some of them are
labeled with y
meaning that there are potential
candidates for the x and y vertices of
the final triangle to be completed
next player 1 draws vertex z
now the adversary can erase an edge
between z and either y1 or y2
suppose the adversary raises an edge
between z and y2 then player 1 draws an
edge between z and y1 in blue
similarly the adversary can erase an
edge between z and either yy1 or y12
suppose the former happens
then player 1 draws an edge between z
and y one two
next the adversary can erase the edge
between z and x two
and player one draws the edge between z
and x one
there are now two potential triangles to
be completed the one between z y1 and x1
and the other between z x1 and y12
the adversary can erase only one of them
suppose it erases this one
then player one colors the remaining
triangle blue thus winning the game
to go from this game to the tester there
are a few other challenges to overcome
first we need to analyze the probability
that the quarries made by the tester are
non-erased when queries because unlike
in the game the tester cannot see the
erasures made by the adversary
secondly the tester does not just want
to catch a completed triangle but it
needs to catch one that violates
quadraticity thus we need to analyze the
probability that the completed triangle
is violating
that concludes our discussion on
quadratic city and now we move on to our
final result on impossibility of testing
sortedness
we represent an array via an integer
valued function whose domain are the
indices 1 through n
the array is sorted is if f of x is at
most f y for indices x less than y
there is a long line of work on
sortedness testing its query complexity
has been pinned down to log of epsilon n
over epsilon it is also possible to test
sortedness with square root of n over
epsilon uniform iad queries
in the model of offline erasures
introduced by dictionary sortedness can
be tested with log n over epsilon
queries
we show that in our model of online
erasures sorted as is impossible to test
even for t equals to 1.
in particular this shows that if a
property can be tested with only uniform
iid queries in the standard model it
does not imply that it is testable in
the online erasers model
to see why sorting s is impossible to
test consider the following array where
adjacent values are inverted and its
values look like 2 1 for 3 6 5 and so on
every value participates in only one
violation to sortedness for example 4
participates in a violation with 3 but
if we look at 4 and any other value in
the array we would not see a violation
thus if the tester were to query 4 the
adversary can erase the adjacent value 3
and so on the tester will never be able
to see a violation
notice that this array is half far from
sorted since a value in each violated
pair has to be modified to make it
sorted
even though it's far from sorted all the
violations assortedness are disjoined
which is what makes this example
impossible to test
on the other hand for properties like
linearity and quadraticity which are
testable in our model whenever a
function is far from that property the
violations have a lot of overlap with
each other that is each point
participating in a violation on average
participates in a lot of other
violations
that concludes the presentation on our
results
to summarize in this work we designed
efficient testers for several important
properties that is linearity and
quadraticity
we showed tight bounds for testing
linearity in terms of the erasure budget
t
and we showed that some basic properties
cannot be tested in our model even for t
equals to 1.
the following are some open questions
first is it possible to test in our
model whether a function is a polynomial
of degree at most k for any k greater
than 3 in the standard model this is
possible with 2 to the k over epsilon
queries
additionally what is the query
complexity for testing quadraticity in
terms of eurasia or budget t
the current ester has query complexity
that is doubly exponential in t which
most likely is not optimal
sortiness is a property that can be
tested in the offline erasers model but
not in the online erasers model
is there a property for which the
opposite holds that is it has smaller
query complexity in the online model
than in the offline model
the two models are not directly
comparable since erasures are budgeted
differently
finally what are other subliner tasks
that can be studied in our online
euragers module
thank you for listening and please get
in touch for any questions